president Trump's impeachment trial is
about to begin but the most important
story of the day is not the Senate
charade that will acquit the president
our political rot runs way deeper all
the way back to the motherland where
Queen Elizabeth is about to D Royal
Prince Harry and Megan Markel we will
examine why that matters we will examine
why with great power comes great
responsibility then the women's March
flops Elizabeth Warren continues her
months long campaign collapse and the
New York Times comes out with its
presidential endorsement plural somehow
because the New York Times doesn't know
what a presidential endorsement is we
will examine the dumbest article on the
Internet today all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
there is so much to get to so we are
going to fly through it we will get to
impeachment we have to get to
impeachment there are details you need
to know going into impeachment week
however the most important story of the
day is not impeachment the more
important story is how we got
impeachment how we got this culture of
complaint how we got this culture of
entitlement if you want to understand
how we got this shallow news cycle this
shallow politics all the way to
impeachment the most important story is
all the way across the Atlantic in the
United Kingdom the most important story
is about the artist formerly known as
Prince Harry and Megan Merkel the most
important story is how with great
privilege comes great responsibility
so the the Sussex is Prince Harry and
Megan Markel they announced that they're
going to leave the royal family in some
way according to the press release they
put out they want to keep all the perks
of being Royals they want the nice
houses and they want the fancy titles
and they want the global celebrity but
they don't want the downside to being
Royals they don't want to have to appear
at public functions they don't want to
have to give access to the British press
when they don't want to they don't want
to be as one
a royal insider or commentator said
civil servants with a tiara on they
don't want all of that now they issue
this statement they say they're gonna
leave the royal family Queen Elizabeth
is totally blindsided by it they have a
big family meeting to hash out how this
is gonna work and the Queen made the
right decision which is to say the these
Royals Harry and and Megan cannot keep
the perks of the job if they're not
gonna do the job itself it's like any
millennial who's going to get his first
job after college who says yeah great I
want that nice paycheck and I want a
really cushy corner office with a couch
over here but I'm probably gonna I'm
gonna roll in maybe 11 o'clock and I
don't want to do all that like paperwork
and stuff I I think I'll come in here
play some video games maybe take a
two-hour lunch and then get out of here
make sure you get that direct deposit so
that I don't need to go to the bank cuz
I just want the money to go straight
into my wallet that it's what the Royals
are behaving
and so Queen Elizabeth said no no no
nunu no my Diaz no they are being
stripped of their royal titles so his
royal highness or her royal highness
that's going away they are going to have
to pay back the British public for their
taxpayer renovated castle they're going
to lose virtually all of the perks of
the job
the liberal media in the US and in the
UK are saying that this is about racism
they're saying that that actually it's
not about the fact that they don't want
to do their jobs they don't want to have
any royal duties and they want all the
perks it's really about how much the
British people and probably the
Americans to hate Megan Markel because
she's black of course many people don't
even know that Megan Markel is is part
black because she she looks very
fair-skinned but that's of course the
left always wants to claim that racism
is the cause of every problem
Megan Merkel's father from whom she is
estranged and who I think she's
currently suing or vice versa this said
that this is not about racism what this
is really about is this spoiled child
tarnishing the royal family so Megan
Markel's father said quote it's
disappointing because she actually got
every girl's dream every young girl
wants to become a princess and she got
that and now she's tossing that away it
looks like she's tossing that way for
money this is like one of the greatest
long living institutions ever referring
to the British monarchy they are
destroying they are cheapening it they
are making it shabby and it's it's
difficult to disagree with that
she got every girl's dream right you
imagine that you can are gonna be
whisked away and marry prince charming
importantly he's a prince
whenever you talk about that and then
she realized she doesn't want the
reality of being a princess she doesn't
want the job she'd rather play a
princess on TV she'd rather work as an
actress she'd rather have her own money
and have control over her life unlike
the Royals who really don't have a ton
of control over their lives according to
a close friend of Megan Markel who was
speaking to the Daily Mail she said this
is this is the friend Megan felt she had
to escape because living within the
royal confines was soul-crushing
mehgan's friend said that that megan can
now finally breathe since leaving and
has free reign over her life again
and that megan felt that living within
the royal family was a toxic environment
and she wanted to leave in part for the
benefit of her son who was it was
constraining and now she gets to be in
control of her life she this is the the
money quote she felt like she couldn't
be the best mother to Archie if she
wasn't being her true authentic self and
she felt she couldn't do that within the
royal confines authenticity following
your true desire and forget about this
Duty forget about what the palace is
foisting on the Royals forget about what
society is foisting on us we we
shouldn't be born with these obligations
in these duties we should just be able
to pursue our true authentic selves who
we know we are deep deep down this is a
rot that runs for in the UK it runs in
America it runs all across the West
which is the cult of the self the idea
that my true self is actually just my
own individual desires
I am the sum total of my individual
desires any constraints are bad and
therefore we need to push them away
whether those constraints are moral
theirs whether their sexual whether
their social whether their official
whether they're political whatever you
got to get rid of the constraints
because we need to pursue our own
desires that is a very modern idea of
our true selves the the that's a very
liberal idea of our true selves the
conservative idea of course is not that
we're just popping into existence as
some free-floating atoms out there in
the universe and we have all our desires
and no one can tell us what to do the
conservative ideas that were born into a
family in a place in a time in a
community in a city in a state in a
country and we have obligations we have
bonds of affection and loyalty we
actually do Oh people something our life
is not our own I didn't create my life
I'm not responsible for popping into
this world and I owe something to my
parents I owe something to my community
I owe something to my god and I'm going
to try
I to fulfill those obligations with
privilege comes duty comes
responsibility and that's true if you're
in Buckingham Palace and it's true if
you're on the street somewhere in New
York it is a privilege to be alive it is
a privilege to live in this time and in
this place and we have an obligation for
that
I'll give you an another example of
wanting the perks without the
responsibilities there's a guy who i
I've tried not to criticize him because
clearly he's got a few things a couple
screws loose I don't know what's going
on he's a blue checkmark named David and
leave it kind of an anti-trump tweet or
tweets a lot about politics he went on a
Twitter rampage over the weekend because
he was in a Target store and he wanted
to buy an electric toothbrush electric
toothbrushes are expensive cost what 50
hundred bucks usually and he saw that
they had a display model that was priced
at one cent because you're not gonna buy
the display model right so he saw one
cent for the electric toothbrush he goes
he said okay I want to pay one cent for
this and the cashier said oh that's
obviously a typo you're it costs more
than one cent for a toothbrush and he
has a meltdown he posts a picture of
this poor girl her name is Tori it's
just like this young girl working at
Target posts a picture of her on the
Internet
spreads her face all over to his
followers calls the cops on target has
an investigation to get to the bottom of
this one cent electric toothbrush you
see this a lot with blue checkmarks
whenever any blue checkmark on Twitter
is inconvenience they just start
complaining about it all the time I'm
sure I've done it too everybody does it
if that's an abuse of power you should
not do that well even though even the
social power of having a little blue
checkmark or having a lot of followers
on Twitter or Instagram there is a
responsibility that comes along with
that it's not just about getting
discounts and getting retail workers to
succumb to your will there is a social
responsibility for how you share
information there's a social
responsibility for how you interact with
people though the rules are not merely
suspended because you have desires
this goes all the way through our
presidential race and especially where
the rot really lies in America obviously
we don't have Royals here it doesn't lie
in some palace or castle
it doesn't even primarily lie in DC it
lies in our media who abuse their power
more than anybody we will get to that in
a second
first I want to thank our friends over
at Tommy John's let me tell you guys I
am very particular about the way that I
dress and the way that I feel underneath
what I put on when I dress Tommy John's
are the best boxers I have ever worn
when it comes to comfort down below
there is underwear there are boxers and
then there's Tommy John the
revolutionary clothing brand that has
redefined comfort for Americans
everywhere including me I there is such
a difference between your
run-of-the-mill boxer shorts that you
pick up at the store and Tommy John's
Tommy John focuses on the three EPs
fabric fit and function Tommy John
obsesses over every little detail and
stitch by using proprietary fabrics that
perform like nothing you have ever worn
before it's comfortable the waist bands
are great really really soft really
really light it's just phenomenal I've
never I've never worn better shorts
Tommy John is so confident that if you
don't love your first pair you can get a
full refund with their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee if you
would prefer to shop in stores and
brick-and-mortar there are 1,200 retail
locations across the country including
Nordstrom stores nationwide Tommy John
no adjustment needed whatsoever once you
go Tommy John you will not go back I'm
promising you that hurry - Tommy John
comm / Knowles right now you get 20% off
your first order you're welcome that's
Tommy John comm / Knowles Kenner wles
20% off your first order Tommy John comm
/ Knowles all right I want to do a quick
little roundup on just some of the
events that have gone on in DC the
events that the news are going to be
talking about and then we will see the
true rotten corruption of the mainstream
their absolute abuse of power so the
women's March happened this weekend
didn't notice it me neither
nobody went the thing absolutely
collapsed in its attendance so it was
estimated that in in 2017 the first year
of the women's March there were three
point three to 5.3 million people who
turned out in cities around the country
so not just Washington Washington was
probably under a million but all around
the country there are a bunch of women's
marches it may have been the largest
single-day protest in US history the
next year by 2018 those numbers dropped
to 1.9 million to 2.6 million so they
dropped by half in 2019 that dropped to
six hundred seventy-six thousand to
seven hundred forty seven thousand
estimated this year I think it was like
a dozen people I mean just nobody showed
up to this thing it barely made a blip
there's no coverage of that next weekend
we're going to have the March for Life
and there gonna be a lot of people at
the March for Life in DC I promise you
that there'll be a lot of people at the
march for life across the country the
mainstream media don't want to cover it
they would rather focus on events like
the women's March which really has
nothing to do with women per se it's
just all about antitrump anti
conservatism here is the kind of caliber
of protest you get at the women's March
[Music]
screeching screaming uh if this F that
getting little kids out there to scream
vulgarity is an obscenity f this F that
obviously a dereliction of duty for
parents obviously a dereliction of duty
and abuse of power from the media who
are giving this so much attention and
it's a corseting of society it's a
society that has never been there has
never been a freer society in the
history of the world there has never
been a more equitable more just society
in the history of the world
and we're abusing that power that we're
abusing that power in our personal
behavior we're abusing it the way that
we demonstrate and we're abusing it in
the political process so we're gonna
start impeachment this week the
president is going to trial this is only
the third impeachment trial in the
history of the United States
with that we had won in the 19th century
President Johnson then we then Richard
Nixon resigned before he could be
impeached then we had Bill Clinton in
the 90s now we have President Trump it
is increasing and what's so bizarre
about this impeachment trial is in many
ways it's a kind of reversal or a replay
of the Clinton impeachment because on
president Trump's legal team you find
Ken stark and star was the special
prosecutor against Bill Clinton now he's
defending President Trump
you've got Ken Starr and you've got Alan
Dershowitz so Alan Dershowitz is the
harvard law professor he doesn't even
like Trump politically he didn't vote
for Trump in 2016 he says he's not
planning on voting for Trump in 2020 but
he is showing up on behalf of the
Constitution to explain why Democrats
are abusing their power and why no
impeachable offense has been committed
and why this is a threat to our
constitutional system here's professor
Dershowitz my role is limited I'm only
going to appear on behalf of the
Constitution making the arguments
against impeachment based on the
Constitution I'm not part of the
strategic legal team I won't be involved
in the debate over whether there are
witnesses or no witnesses or whether or
not facts come out one way or the other
this is a role I've played before in
other cases I'm a specialist in
constitutional law I've written three
books and probably 25 articles on the
impeachment clauses of the Constitution
so I will appear on Friday make my
argument to the Senate about the
constitutional reasons why these two
articles of impeachment don't satisfy
the criteria and then I'll answer
questions from the Senators but that
will be the extent of my role so
Dershowitz is this rare individual in
American politics didn't used to be so
rare but these days he is he's a guy who
says I'm going to divorce my legal
opinion from my political preferences
starting in the 1960s the American Left
said the personal is the political so
there was no difference between the
public and the private what I personally
want and what I can objectively say is
true
alan dershowitz is the lone dissenter
from that he says I don't like Trump I
didn't vote for Trump but I'm standing
up for the Constitution because we have
this wonderful constitutional system
here that we are throwing away because
we're getting so greedy we're getting so
selfish
we're so self-interested there's a great
irony to this that Nancy Pelosi has
foisted this on the country because
Nancy Pelosi during the Clinton
impeachment talked about how the
impeachment of Bill Clinton was all just
about the personal grievances of
Republicans who hated Clinton who were
out to get him and now she's doing
exactly the same thing here's Nancy
Pelosi Ben right now we have a situation
where any and all grievances that
anybody ever had with the president are
being heaped on and talking about
impeachment without even defining what
the laws may have been that were broken
with applying the facts to them without
even defining if even if those laws were
broken if that amounts to an impeachable
offense now let's be clear what Nancy
Pelosi is saying is not true the the
case of the Clinton impeachment and the
Trump impeachment are not comparable
whatever you think about the Clinton
impeachment and with all the political
aspects that all impeachments have
obviously Republicans wanted to get the
guy they didn't like him however Bill
Clinton clearly committed an impeachable
offense he perjured himself he lied
under oath he admitted that he lied to
the American people said I did not have
sexual relations with that woman
uh-huh and then he had the gall the
temerity when when asked about this to
say that it depends on what the
definition of is is okay the guy lied
what is the impeachable offense that
Trump has committed he made a phone call
to Ukraine he six out of seven of the
House impeachment managers supported
impeachment before anybody even knew
about the Ukraine phone call he didn't
commit an impeachable offense but even
so let's even say he did surely Nancy
Pelosi could apply her own logic from
the nineties of the present except she
can't because politics for the left has
become all about personal preference not
about the objective criteria of the
Constitution not about divorcing the
personal from the political
about accepting the duty that comes with
being a representative in a republic
such as ours just forcing your will on
the people now of course this has helped
President Trump we're gonna we'll give
you a lot of coverage of impeachment all
week we'll give you what you need to
know impeachment is help Trump from the
very beginning from day one this guy has
been raising a ton of money on it and
his approval ratings have increased the
mainstream media though are trying to
twist this so Trump has absolutely blown
past any of his Democratic rivals and
their presidential campaigns in terms of
fundraising but the way the mainstream
media is trying to spin it is they're
saying well sure that's true but the
Democratic field as a whole has
outraised Donald Trump when you combine
all the 355 candidates who are running
as Democrats they have outraised Donald
Trump therefore Trump is probably going
to lose that's that's what the
mainstream media are thrilled to report
CNBC the 2020 Democratic field is out
raising Trump by a huge margin that
didn't happen to Obama or Bush okay I
mean that doesn't tell you the whole
story
it doesn't imply the Democrats are gonna
beat Trump right because Obama raised
more relative to his GOP challengers in
2012 then Trump is raising now relative
to his Democratic challengers but in
2012 the Republican field as a whole out
raised Obama it's the same situation so
if what the mainstream media were
suggesting is true we would probably be
toward the end of the second Romney term
right now and we'd be getting ready for
the Paul Ryan presidential run but we're
not are we cuz that's not how it works
now it wasn't true of Bush Bush not only
outraised in 2004 his Democratic
challengers he out raised all of them
combined the incumbent George Bush the
Republican out raised all of those
Democratic contenders combined so what
is this show right now it doesn't show
that because the field is out raising
Trump they're gonna whoever the
Democratic nominee is is going to beat
Trump just as Romney didn't beat Obama
what it shows is greater polarization
shows people are paying closer attention
to politics shows people are much more
tuned into politics politics has become
more of a
sport they're more willing to part with
their money to give to Olli on Castro er
or Tim Ryan or any some of these
candidates who just have no chance of
winning that's greater engagement and I
fear what that means is people are
making it much much more personal it's
not cool it's not objective we're seeing
this at the at the mainstream media
level when we talk about those
candidates so Elizabeth Warren just
dropped another doozy of a lie Elizabeth
Warren who formerly was the rising star
she had all the momentum she was gonna
be the top of the field she was gonna
get the nomination her campaign has
collapsed and so she's desperately
trying to pitch herself as the the best
candidate for the voters at an Iowa
campaign stuff she had one of the one of
the great lives of her campaign which is
defined by them she said quote let me
remind you I think I'm the only one
running for president who's actually
been on the executive side what does she
mean by executive she's running against
Mike Bloomberg Mike Bloomberg is one of
the most successful executives in
American business it also she's running
against Bloomberg who was the mayor of
New York and Budaj edge was the mayor of
his small town in Indiana and Bernie
Sanders who was the mayor of Vermont
they've all been executives and
Elizabeth Warren hasn't been an
executive she's been a professor and a
senator in her imagination she was
obviously a chieftain on the Great
Plains but she didn't actually do that
that was just a fantasy of hers that she
tried to convince the American people of
now she might mean that she's the only
one who's worked in the executive branch
because she had that Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau so she ran this little
executive agency she set it up but she's
running against Joe Biden right Joe
Biden worked in the executive branch I
guess technically the vice president is
the president of the Senate which is
legislative but come on give me a break
he's the vice president and the
president is the executive I think he
worked in the executive branch
he ran initiatives Joe Biden from the
executive branch much bigger initiatives
than Elizabeth Warren have a race she's
just
congenitally dishonest she actually she
was asked about these lies her opus
implied her own lies and she was asked
if it's okay to lie to the American
public she couldn't even say no is it
disqualifying for
[Music]
I think that we just do our best and I
hope
how can she bungle that question that's
the simplest question hey Canada do you
think it's ok to lie well I mean you
know and but obviously the reason she
has to hem and haw over it is because
she has famously lied about her DNA her
Indian ancestry that doesn't exist she
lied about being fired for being
pregnant she lied about her child's
education she lies about everything
and so she can't even answer the
question is it disqualifying to lie
because it would disqualify her that's
why she keeps dropping in the polls
right her campaign the American people
have seen through it I think I think
certainly the American people have even
the Democratic primary voters appear to
be seeing through it a survey USA
nationwide democratic poll shows
Elizabeth Warren just keeps dropping
down so right now in first place is
Biden still 32% in second place is
Bernie 21% Liz Warren is now down at 14%
that's a big drop from when she was
poised to become the front-runner the
people are seeing through her charade
and yet the mainstream media are still
carrying water for her and this this
brings us right back to the power and
responsibility this shows a major flaw
from the American left check out this
crock that came out from MSNBC on the
Bernie Warren battle of who's telling
the truth about Bernie's alleged
comments that a woman couldn't win in
2020
it would seem that Bernie's telling the
truth here he's got the better track
record there's no reason to believe that
he's lying there is reason to believe
that Warren is lying they can't prove
that Warren's telling the truth so MSNBC
brings on a body language expert
whatever that is to talk about how
really really when you look and when you
think about it really hard Bernie's
probably lying the thing about the this
dust-up between the two of them is that
scandals hurt you more when they seem
plausible right because I mean Bernie
Sanders does have a sort of physicality
when he when he talks that is a shaking
your fingers at Hillary Clinton shaking
your finger push of the we're deeper you
know his physicality
he makes me think yeah he could have
said you're not listen I think in this
environment a woman can't wait that
doesn't seem like a person I think I
think Bernie's lying shovey weirdy a
shaky shovey weirdy that is what passes
for political analysis on the left man I
got to get a new job because when I when
I try to prepare some political analysis
on the right I need to look at facts and
figures and data history I have to
incorporate all of that if I'm on the
left I could just talk about my fields
and that would that would pass for
political commentary this is your brain
on ideology this is your brain on
ideology where they just say yeah
there's no evidence that Bernie's lying
but he's kind of shaky weirdy he's kind
of my own you know and then the other
woman says yeah I think he's lying as if
his body language that's your brain on
ideology and really what you get from
the left is is intersectionality right
it doesn't matter what Bernie says it
doesn't matter what Warren says they're
they're just judging people on these
superficial characteristics or on these
physical characteristics so they're
judging people on their skin color
they're judging people by their sex and
without examining the particulars of any
circumstance they're saying we have to
believe all women my women can't lie men
do lie so if it's a man versus a woman
the woman has to be telling the truth
the premise of intersectionality is that
people can be divided up in a hierarchy
of oppression and the more oppressed
people more allegedly oppressed people
must always be believed over less
oppressed people so Bernie as an old
white guy three strikes against him old
white guy and so he's less credible than
any kind of woman even if she's only one
1024 Native American or not even that
much more likely and it's not just MSNBC
MSNBC is certainly the most far left
cable network it's not just them it's
also the New York Times this is the most
obvious abuse of power it
industry media going on right now and
it's actually the direct parallel with
what Harry and Megan are doing the New
York Times has offered its endorsement
in the 2020 Democratic presidential
primary but it doesn't want to offer an
endorsement it's offering two
endorsements it's it's endorsing
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar
that's not how endorsements work you
can't have your cake and eat it too you
can't be all things to all people you
can't be a royal and not have to do any
of the Royal things even the New York
Times editorial board no one thinks
they're gonna endorse Trump or anything
like that but at least make an
endorsement at least make a choice
stop dare electing your duty do your job
they just picked the two women I mean
they I don't even know that they've
listened to these people Elizabeth
Warren is the most grating candidate in
the race and they went for her and they
went for Klobuchar I suspect they just
looked at that little hierarchy of
oppression pyramid and they said I'll
going well - women yep there we go check
the box
I do love - they're so they're so in
their own heads that they don't see the
irony's of what they're doing here is
that it's a very very long editorial you
can read it if you want or don't highly
recommend you don't when they get to
Elizabeth Warren and why they're
endorsing her in addition to Amy
Klobuchar
this is the first sentence I kid you not
the onion couldn't have written it
better Babylon B couldn't have written
it better why are they endorsing Warren
senator Warren is a gifted storyteller
yeah you don't say she does a lot of
stories she tells stories about her DNA
she does stories a better kids education
she tells stories about getting fired
she tells all sorts of stories none of
them have anything to do with the truth
but she tells stories she speaks
elegantly that's what this is that's the
first that the first sentence first two
sentences senator Warren is a gifted
storyteller
she speaks elegantly of how the economic
system is rigged against all the
wealthiest Americans on and on and on
it doesn't open up by saying anything
she's done it says that she spins a good
yarn she tells a good tale much like the
New York Times right that's what the New
York Times does to the New York Times
doesn't necessarily rely on facts
they've spread wholesale lies about
President Trump about the Russia hoax
they've spread all sorts of lies but
they spin a good yarn they write
elegantly you know they have very good
diction and grammar this is an absolute
abuse of power the mainstream media in
this country have a lot of power and the
reason we go after them the reason we go
after the New York Times or less so
MSNBC but occasionally we knock them -
the reason we go after mainstream media
organizations like the New York Times is
not because they're left-wing I don't
care that they're left-wing I often
encourage people to read I don't know
voxcom or even The Huffington Post
because they're clear about their point
of view they're gonna present the
left-wing side of the argument I think
you should be exposed to the left wing
side of the argument so that you can
answer it you can figure out why it's
wrong that's not why we oppose groups
like the New York Times the reason that
the New York Times is so bad for the
country is because they're so corrupt
and they're corrupt because they abuse
their power and you see it in the
frivolity the dereliction of duty in not
choosing a presidential endorsement like
saying yeah I endorsed the Yankees and
the Red Sox for the World Series you
endorsed the Yankees in the right you
got to pick one
you can't pick both of them so they
derelict their duty there and then they
derelict their duty to investigate to
look into facts to to weigh the
arguments on both sides there's another
great abuse that's going on right now
beyond the mainstream media it's
happening in New York just where I
happen to be for the next five or six
hours New York's sanctuary city policy
under Mayor bolshevik bill de blasio is
a disaster here's one example that just
just came out within the past week the
sexual assault and murder of a 92 year
old woman Maria fuertes in Queen
who was raped and killed by an illegal
alien from Guyana who had been detained
is an illegal alien he had been detained
and was released in New York in defiance
of a federal detainer so they get him
they get the illegal alien New York City
says we're gonna be a sanctuary city you
can't tell us what to do Trump you can't
tell us what to do immigration laws you
can't tell us what to do American people
we're gonna release this poor wonderful
illegal alien guess what happens he
raped and killed a 92 year old woman in
Queens would not have happened would not
have happened
if they just followed the law but it's
because New York City bill de blasio
they don't want to do their jobs they
don't want to do the hard things they
want to do the easy things that win them
applause and then derelicte their duty
we'll get to the rest of this story we
will also get to the most insane CNN
Headline and and a little bit we'll
leave you on a little bit of hope as
well but first I've got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube if you are not
already a subscriber what are you doing
what what are you thinking you're
missing out right now using promo code
Knolls que no wles you will get 10% off
any plan you choose head on over to
daily wire that comes slash subscribe
pick the plan that's right for you for
as little as 10 bucks a month
members get our articles add free access
to all our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the
bench bureau show some bonus content
access to the mailbag and a lot more
plus now our all-access tear gets you
into exclusive live online Q&A
discussions with me which would be
enough that would be enough Diana with
Ben with Drew with Matt with daily wire
writers and special guests and don't
forget you will also get the most
wonderful of all beverage vessels the
left is tears tumblr you will get all
that plus 10% off when using promo code
Noll scan or wles so stop depriving
yourself treat yourself a little look
we're living in a great time of
decadence okay everyone else is doing it
you should treat yourself to head on
over join the fun daily we're calm we'll
be right back with a lot more
formal politics is hard it can be a
little dry it's detached it's at its
best dispassionate it requires you to do
hard things
increasingly our elected officials are
not willing to do that nowhere is this
clearer than Bill de Blasio in New York
does anybody really defend in principle
open borders does anybody really I'm not
talking about these crazy people on
Twitter or something I'm talking about
the vast majority of sensible people on
the on the Left I suppose and the center
on the right does anybody really defend
the idea that a people are not allowed
to define their own immigration laws
they really defend the idea that anyone
can go willy-nilly into any country they
want at any time and you can't stop them
I don't think so I think really the way
the argument works for the left is is
just emotional manipulation they say
look at this person look at your good
friend Jose who's an illegal alien who
came here thirty years ago and he's got
the beautiful wonderful family goes to
church on Sunday does his job very well
he's hardworking he's wonderful and he's
more American than apple pie you wanted
to port that guy and say no of course
not everyone likes him he's doing all
the right stuff but in principle we want
to deport illegal aliens and by the way
for every story of a nice guy who's
raising a family and he's been living
the American dream
you get a story of this illegal alien
from Guyana who who commits heinous
crimes and who was released by New York
City in defiance of the federal law in
defiance of a federal detainer because
it's so much easier to to let these guys
go and feel really good and win all the
fields of your radical leftist base now
fortunately the US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement ice is now no longer
requesting that New York follow the law
they are demanding it and henry lucero
who's a senior i sufficient told the AP
this is not
request it's a demand this is a last
resort for us dangerous criminals are
being released every single day in New
York New York City will not change the
policies that have made and this is
according to bill de blasio than he
responds to them you say New York City
will not change the policies that have
made us the safest big city in America
not safe for Murray of Huertas who's no
longer with us and who was tortured at
the end of her life because of your
fecklessness they just they just won't
do it
I mean mayor de Blasio is governing his
city like a child would govern but you
can't do that you can't just get all the
plaudits and all the perks and let
everybody go without enforcing the law
without exacting justice without
following the laws you can't do that so
I'm not terribly hopeful for New York
I'm not terribly hopeful for the left
I'm not terribly hopeful for the
mainstream media but I am generally
hopeful for the country because whenever
you see the the crazy stories out of the
New York Times we're at Buckingham
Palace out of them for the Royals across
the UK or in the Gracie Mansion the
mayor's house in in New York for every
one of those stories you see the
American people looking through the BS
all right that's why Elizabeth Warren's
campaign it needs to be floated by the
New York Times it's why CNN is so
desperate to keep her campaign afloat is
the the voters don't like it they're
seeing through that I mean that's how we
got Trump in 2016 and and Trump just
keeps doing this I mean there there was
it's obviously at the big level the
economy is doing very well jobs are
doing very well these macro policies are
great that we killed that guy sulemani
and Iran but it's even down to the micro
level president Trump this is one of the
great stories put a smile on my face
President Trump announced on Friday that
they plan to roll back school breakfast
and lunch nutrition guidelines that
Michelle Obama pushed so Michelle Obama
took away kids good lunches and made the
meet like one stick of carrots or
something you know just gross nobody
wants that no self-respecting
twelve-year-old wants to eat celery
sticks instead of pizza at lunch let the
kids have their pizza but president
Trump chose to announce this on Michelle
Obama
his birthday I don't think this was a
coincidence I think it was pretty clear
he's really sticking it in the eye and
there's so much of his administration is
a stick in the eye he was elected with
no prior political experience as a stick
in the eye to an establishment that
people feel as is no longer representing
them and to an establishment that people
feel is dare electing their duty that
goes to fancy lunches and talks about
how wonderful they all are and has their
blue checkmarks and complains all the
time and and really sneers and looks
with disdain on their fellow Americans
but we're not actually doing their job
they're not doing the journalism they're
not doing the governing they're not
they're not doing what they are supposed
to be doing and so we elected president
Trump and from trade policy in China to
policy geopolitics and foreign affairs
in the Middle East to school lunches on
Michelle Obama's birthday he he is
acting as that stick in the eye and it's
why many people will say I don't like
Trump I don't like his tweets I don't
like the way he behaves but darn it I
like what he's doing and and looking
forward to 2020 that argument hasn't
changed and the left hasn't offered an
alternative they haven't learned that
lesson another stick in the eye Trump
just tweeted out is New York wants 200
billion dollars for a seawall because
global warming is gonna sink New York
remember Al Gore predicted this 15 years
ago and then it didn't happen and he
predicted it about Florida and it didn't
happen but anyway they want to build
that wall they want to build a seawall
to protect New York from the Sun monster
they don't want to build a wall on our
southern border to prevent the illegal
aliens who are flooding into this
country from coming over no they're
going to protect us from from climate
Armageddon so Trump tweets out about
this he says quote a massive two hundred
billion dollar seawall built around New
York to protect it from rare storms is a
costly foolish and environmentally
unfriendly idea that when needed
probably won't work anyway it will also
look terrible sorry you'll just have to
get your mops and buckets ready
I think that could be the slogan of his
campaign get your mops and buckets ready
referring not just to the rare storms
but also to the constant torrent of
leftist tears get your mops and buckets
ready
Trump 2020 I think that's a pretty
serious pitch regardless of what you
think of a guy like Trump the message of
the Trump campaign is hey shut up with
the complaining shut up with the
microaggressions shut up with the
political correctness shut up with
looking down on your fellow Americans
and just do your job be happy things are
going well the economy is great when he
jokes about how he's the greatest
president ever he's your favorite
president ever what lies at the bottom
of that joke and the kind of egotism and
the bragging is a certain gratitude hey
things are going pretty well if you
can't enjoy this right now when are you
going to enjoy it if really if you put
your hope in politics which is a bad
idea but if you do that and you can't
have a good time in politics while your
rights are being protected while
consumer confidence is up manufacturing
confidence is up we're killing the top
terrorists in the world we're getting
stronger trade deals where if you
unemployment isn't record lows across
every demographic if you can't enjoy
that politics you're never going to
enjoy politics you're just going to
complain and whine and it will ever be
good enough that's not the right way to
think about it don't don't look at
politics from a perspective of
entitlement and rights primarily look at
it from a perspective of gratitude and
duty and obligation
this was uncontroversial when JFK said
it at his inauguration half a century
ago asking not what your country can do
for you but what you can do for your
country
now that is very controversial and the
American left and even part of the right
doesn't want to believe it and it's why
over in the UK you get people like the
artist formerly known as Prince Harry
and in America you get the shrieking
left and the feckless and irresponsible
news media that are going to be covering
a feckless and irresponsible impeachment
from feckless and irresponsible cities
like New York all the way to Washington
DC all around the
country well we will be covering them
and I bet we're gonna have a great time
doing it as the leftist tears flow so
get your mops and buckets ready that's
our show I'm Michael Nolt this is the
Michael Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you